[Applause]
opposition leader Nelson Chamisa says he
is ready for the rematch with Emerson
manangagwa Zimbabwe's president five
years ago he came close to beating
Managua in the presidential election and
he won zimbabweans to choose him saying
the country needs a new kind of leader
[Applause]
for you
poverty High inflation unemployment and
Corruption are frustrating everyday
concerns for most people here now
his supporters say that is what Zimbabwe
needed help he'll bring new ideas to
turn around the economy
president is turning 81 years old he
says he's not worried his own repair
party has governed Zimbabwe for 43 years
the man called the crocodile is
confident his large projects such as
roads airports and mines will get him
re-elected
Zimbabwe's leader promises free fair and
transparent elections I
do not come to observe us with
foregone conclusions from your homes
or your countries
[Music]
[Applause]
we
are
a peaceful peaceful people opposition
leaders are already alleging for
treating and manipulation elections here
are often disputed zimbabweans will know
in a few days which way this one is
going to go
Harare